ils viennent d'annoncer le confinement
savard contient courte le test
envisageons mon visage je déteste autant
visage tu déteste mon visage oui je suis
pas je te déteste
cette départ nous deux c'était une
énorme erreur n'importe quoi est ce que
est ce que c'est un effet du confinement
ou est-ce que ça arrive à d'autres
personnes il y à un champignon bien
précis il n'est pas mortel mais
j'adorerais rapporté un de ces
champignons et voir crever cette espèce
de politique
ya strictement plus rien entre nous à
part le petit arthur qu'il faut être
juste tu m'as donné un fils génial je ne
tenais pas donné
maintenant je trouve que tu as un peu
près autant de charme que diarrhées dans
un verre de bière
je m'inquiète pour ma mère artichauts il
n'a plus quelqu'un grands parents
c'était étrange à l'hôpital c'était mais
bon ils font ce qu'ils peuvent pour que
les patients demeurent pas seul moi mes
deux parents sont morts heureusement
c'est super déprimant oui c'est ce que
j'ai pensé en le disant déprimant
il va falloir qu'on s'entendre je te
déteste pas maman mais je ne te méprise
jamais
je veux pas que tout rentre dans l'ordre
se précipiter les uns vers les autres à
la vitesse de la lumière en clans
éloignez vous de loin à cette vie je ne
supporte plus
on l'a fait dans la cuisine ce matin sur
le lave-vaisselle franchement c'est
incompréhensible
est-ce que ça va vous dit
je crois qu'il ya une chance pour qu'on
en soit au point où l'amour arrive après
l'aisne
c'est unique tu as entendu ça dans une
chanson bien
[Musique]
ce qu'on fait la saveur qui à dire pour
moi ce que j'éprouve pour toi tu vois
c'est trop bizarre c'est une façon de me
dire que tu m'aimes non c'est une façon
de te dire
que quelque part je t'aime
hier j'ai pleuré dans mon bas
dans mon bar